greetings everyone here you can see
expert Farmers harvesting billions of
strawberries here in California USA we
find ourselves at a picturesque
Strawberry Farm
today here in this video we'll show you
the incredible steps these Farms take to
produce and harvest billions of
strawberries annually here we are in the
Farm's Nursery area
[Music]
expert Farmers here choose only the
finest strawberries for planting in the
official
Fields by using this selection process
we can be sure that every strawberry
plant has the chance to grow strongly
and produce a good crop because we only
plant the healthiest plants with the
best growth and development potential
impressive performance additional
laborers are diligently preparing the
beds and soil for the impending arrival
of thousands of strawberry plants
California's strawberry farms are among
the most productive in the world thanks
to the hard work and expertise of the
Farm Workers who tend to them keep
watching to find out how these tasty
berries are a Foodies Journey beginning
in
2021 from the farm to the table in the
Santa Maria region alone 37,000 acres
are devoted to Strawberry farming in
California Within These carefully
prepared zones thousands of strawberry
plants are primed and ready to be
planted midwe through August is when
most farms in California begin their
planting
season surprisingly no matter the season
California grows more than 10 distinct
strawberry varieties each with its own
planting and harvesting schedule if you
ever find yourself in
California make sure to stop by the
Strawberry
Fields not only do locals there use
traditional root planting methods but
they also use machines
[Music]
once the seedlings are chosen the
planting process can
start strawberry growing process
[Music]
begins ideal depths and distances for
drilling holes are achieved with the
help of modern technology which has
revolutionized
traditional planting methods next the
seedlings are carefully placed into the
pre-drilled holes by the
[Music]
farmers this method guarantees uniform
growth while also making the most
efficient use of the available
[Music]
Land California strawberries are
available all year round and farmers can
plant thousands of seedlings per hour
which great L reduces labor costs and
increases productivity with the help of
advanced watering systems hardworking
Farm Workers make sure that every
strawberry plant gets the water it needs
after planting on average each
strawberry plant needs about 2 in of
water per day but that number increases
dramatically during the fruiting season
every year around 55,000 workers mostly
from Mexico descend upon the Farm to
help with the
Harvest the varied climate of California
allows for a wide variety of strawberry
varieties to thrive and it takes about
60 to 90 days for the flowers to bloom
once they do millions of honeybees are
brought in to pollinate the fruit
trees these diligent bees play a crucial
role in agriculture offering vital
pollination service services that
bolster crop productivity head to
California's Strawberry Fields where
their pay is directly tied to the amount
of boxes they
pick recent statistics show that the
average worker earns around $15 per
hour with baskets and all the necessary
tools they carefully select the ripe
strawberries making sure not to bruise
them
then they transfer the strawberries to
packing facilities where they are sorted
and shipped to
markets the strawberries are sorted
cleaned and packaged before being sent
to stores and supermarkets all over the
country this process demands great
precision and attention to detail
because strawberries are fragile and
quickly spoiled so it is essential that
they are harvested and transported
swiftly to guarantee that consumers
receive strawberries of high quality one
in 2012 strawberries were produced in
California to the tune of 1.1 million
tons or
91% of the nation's total this thriving
industry brings in $2.1
billion as a
[Music]
year interestingly the Harvest goes on
as usual at these Farms even when it
rains as of the Year
2023 indicate the end of the strawberry
growing
season the production of strawberries in
California increased slightly to
1.15 million tons ensuring that the
state continues to dominate the US
market with 92%
of the total production forecasts for
2024 indicate that the industry will
continue to grow with $2.3 billion in
annual revenue thanks to improvements in
farming techniques and more resilient
crop varieties that can withstand harsh
weather in approximately 2 weeks the
fields will be prepared for a new crop
to emerge and
Thrive tell us what you think about the
strawberry farming process shown in this
video by leaving a comment
below we appreciate you taking the time
to watch and hope you enjoyed this
inside look at strawberry
farming stay tuned for our next video
where we'll explore the fascinating
world of agriculture in more
depth subscribe and turn on
notifications so you don't miss it
[Music]
as we embark on our next thrilling
adventure we appreciate you being here
today
[Music]
you
here
[Music]